during an interview with the president  today he had quite a bit to say about  migration across Europe as well as about  Angela Merkel the woman waving migrants  into Europe like a third-base coach  here's part of it Angela was a superstar  until she allowed millions of people to  come into Germany that really hurt her  badly as you know she was unbeatable in  any election she allowed millions of  people to come in I will say this she's  been very badly hurt by immigration and  it went on and got more interesting than  any interview I've done with him in a  long time maybe ever the full extended  interview airs tomorrow night 8:00 p.m.  Eastern and we hope that you will tune  in then